David Harbour plays a small but key
character with somebody like David this
is a Netflix movie how much is it you
saying I think David Harbour would be
great and how much is it for like a role
like that Netflix saying David Arbor is
very popular to our audience maybe you
should put David harborin yeah it's a
little bit of both because you know
we're going through and there was a list
of people that I wanted to try to get
ahold of for that part and you know we
put some offers out and some people
weren't available some people were
interested but then you know when you're
going through it then when David Harbor
came up I think it might have been it
was Jeff well
Seraphin was our casting director she's
great so she's always giving ideas and
then then Joe we mention didn't David
and I could actually be really great as
soon as his name came up as a
possibility Netflix was like hey these
are the numbers you know the logistics
of it is a huge audience on Netflix this
could be a really good choice so you
know they're not saying you have to hire
him but they're like in the background
going still late do it and so you take
that into consideration and what it
worked out you know he's like he's a
great actor a cool dude and he brought
something very unique to the to the role
and I think it was the right choice
you know and he has a huge following on
Netflix already that sequence is really
the one fight sequence that risk gets
beaten in the movie David kind of takes
him down obviously he's hurt from the
arm and whatever else but could you sort
of talk about crafting that fight and
the fact that it is the only time that
Chris loses in a fight yeah we we tried
to you know he felt it was necessary in
that moment for to kind of justify the
the use of deadly force by the VAIO be
is to put rake in a compromised position
to where his life was in danger and it
did come up you know we discussed like
how is you know this guy gonna beat him
but then we discussed it in our
backstory is that those two guys here's
spoiler who knows where these that
prequels or sequels or whatever could
possibly go if this Netflix likes the
movie
their backstory is these guys have
trained together and you know and they
just kind of took they grew it and I
grew up but like spend a lot of time
together in their service and you know
in the military and even outside of that
and kind of like you know private
military sector and they there's skills
I think that would be matched but then
they just went in different directions
you know Harbor went kind of native and
you say you kind of found a life in
Bangladesh and stayed there and rate
kind of kept going down that path but
their skill set if you've matched them
up they're kind of evenly matched and so
to make up for you know the fact that
Rick has been doing consistently and you
know harbors character had not we make
sure that if Chris had enough damage if
he was beaten down enough when we
believe that harbor had the skills to
you know to take him down I didn't even
think about that you guys could
essentially make a prequel movie with
David and Chris teaming up to do
something yeah I mean there's a lot of
potential it's it's so interesting and
again the beauty of it and people and
anything are so ambiguous anything is
that they you know there's a lot of ways
you can go you can either go forwards or
backwards and either way you look on the
timeline or very interesting stories
have you actually discussed when you
were on set or after you've wrapped now
have you actually discussed with David
and Chris an idea for a prequel or is
this sort of like pie in the sky you
know what I mean no I mean it wasn't
there wasn't something on set it was
something that although you know what as
soon as it got mentioned that you know
the thought of the sequel because I
guess Netflix was enjoying the the
dailies and things were coming together
and people were like ah this is this
couldn't be you know if you talk about
all these things is he is it a franchise
is that all these things who knows until
the movie comes out and the audience
response they'll be the ones who you
know who decide but it was talked about
and as soon as it was you know kind of
Joe brought up an interesting point that
like most of the time you get a sequel
rarely do you you know go back in time
into prequels and so then the discussion
became it was very interesting billing
okay
you're it's that you know you get harbor
and Chris cuz they have a great
chemistry on-screen it's very fun
yeah tints is kind of a cool interaction
they have so we thought that's a very
interesting way if you were to go
backwards in time that you could play
out the you know the prequel to a story
like this also David's a big dude and
Chris is like they look like they're
evenly matched if you will you know with
you know in terms of size and presence I
would love to see them to you know
fights like but I saw an extraction you
know no yeah ya know there's a lot of
but they're both you know both great
actors both you know physically kind of
the similarly you know size are the two
big guys and that was um you know part
of the idea of the casting is it had to
be somebody who could stand toe-to-toe
with Chris and you would believe that he
could you know have a chance because
Chris is a big strong intimidating guy
not intimidating and like a personal
since he's the nicest guy in the world
but has a presence in the movie with
that character that's very you know very
intimidating